Dear President,
ladies and gentlemen,
that was countergendered
quite simple actually.
It does not hurt and I do it even in everyday life
voluntarily.
Sounds funny,
but is so
for many people
for many.
I do it so that they understand me too.
Don't worry to pay attention,
for many people
makes a huge difference
and it hurts everyone else
is not that simple,
that's what you would think.
Nevertheless,
have.
Again we have again because of them from the AfD
such a discussion here at pledo,
in which they
due to lack of expertise in any area.
So honestly,
what can they actually do
again put the topic of gender on the tray here?
And at the same time they whine,
that you can't just talk about gender,
but should talk about real problems.
Okay, good,
that's how we do it.
Let's talk about it,
that women on the way to the few practices,
offer theSchwangerschaftsabbr,
be harassed and threatened.
Let's talk about it,
that violence against queer people
is at a peak,
we talk about it,
that refugees burn shelters
and let's talk about it,
what role the AfD plays in this hate and agitation
plays.
Of course,
they don't want that.
You try
their inhuman ideology
still somehow connectable.
And since gender is unusual for many people,
many don't want to do it either,
so this is 1 favorite topic of the AfD.
It's totally okay,
by the way,
not wanting to gender
Language does not change over time through coercion
and there is nowhere to be,
no matter how often.
You claim that
so except of course in Thuringia now,
where the AfD hand in hand with the CDU
has enforced the compulsion to the generic masculine.
on that.
There is a large number of scientific studies in the process,
that clearly prove,
that the use of the generic masculine
leads to women and queere
People are made invisible
Example for completion.
There are a hell of a lot of s in the AfD.
There we automatically think of men
and make with it the women,
who want to shoot children at the borders
or want to the state,
invisible.
But they are just as dangerous
like the men in the AfD
and belong just as little in this parliament.